all right everybody pays attention no
one gets hurt
go open the door they'll get worse than
her
hey hey
come on
let's go shut up shut the [ __ ] up come
on in the back come on what are you
doing
hands right your back come on nestor
we're giving you everything you want i
don't even
[Laughter]
get in there
sit tight i'll handle the plastic don't
blow yourself up
pay attention what's he doing
he's
[Music]
all set phone it in
i'm making the call
[Music]
all right i'm gonna do this
show me the money
slow and steady t slow and steady
[Music]
there's enough here for us all to enjoy
depends on how you look at it
what's the holdup
coming out me
[Music]
i saw your face i'll remember you you
get a thousand things every day how
about you make sure this is one of them
i've seen his eyes he's crazy no one's
crazy i think
be cool
but
[Music]
it'll be quick
problem
[ __ ]
you didn't have to do that let's get
going there'll be time for grieving
later yeah you got that right
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing
find some cover
i'm sending the charges you're on a
timer so break yourself
[Music]
oh [ __ ] you hear that
siren [ __ ] the cops t hit the shutter
switch
what's this local resistance it ain't
supposed to go down like this it never
is come on
get out of
here blame the pricks who called you out
here if i'm gonna die i'm gonna die
breathing right
get in their faces
come on guys
they answered the wrong call
you shouldn't have been a cop
let's move come on
what the [ __ ] is this
get out of the way
press forward
get down
can't be many more cops in this town
it's as [ __ ] man the thing is plum i
got my share it's still wide open
drop it brick
don't be as dumb as you look
let's go get to the car
i hope he's waiting
dumb [ __ ] cops
we got a window let's go
let's move it
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
you in here
what took you so long shut the [ __ ] up
and drive
did you see that [ __ ] i can put that
bitch's face against the glass do you
see that yeah you're a real scout
[Music]
[ __ ] get out here
go go
come on let's get to the chopper
we move quick we can beat the train
we're getting there
cops coming our way be cool they ain't
made this car yet
man i believe in this bird when i get
eyes on it
[ __ ] [ __ ] dick roadblock go right beat
the train man
you guys all right
[ __ ]
come on
ditch the car all right we can go this
way to the chopper no hey
stick to the plan
what
stick to the [ __ ] plan come on
where the [ __ ] is the chopper
someone must have [ __ ] talked
all right brad's gonna be fine we gotta
get
[Music]
i'm standing here finish me
suckers
you [ __ ] caught stalkers
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] stay back you come here
go go
[Music]
michael
was not always a good husband
not always a good citizen
he did not die a hero's death
but he was a man
our lord
was crucified with two thieves
so perhaps
we should not judge
we are born of sin and we die in sin
and in this
michael
just like anybody else
father
we do not know your infinite mysteries
but we know
that you will show mercy to our friends
your son james
he's a good kid
he's a good kid
a good kid
why
does he help the [ __ ] poor
no
he sits on his ass all day
smoking dope and jerking off while he
plays that [ __ ] game
if that's our standard for goodness no
wonder this country's screwed
and what about you
what about me
hey
i don't have the advantages that kid has
by the time i was his age i'd already
been in prison twice
i robbed banks
i ran [ __ ] smuggled dope and you
consider them achievements these were
the opportunities i had at least i took
them and where did these opportunities
get you michael
they got me right
[ __ ] here
the end of the road
with a big house and a useless kid and
i'm stuck talking to you because no one
else gives a [ __ ] oh i'm living the
dream baby and that dream is [ __ ] it
is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
let it all out
i think i just did
oh
well i
think that's all we have time for
the same time next week
i guess
oh
i gotta tell you i ain't too sure this
[ __ ] is working for me hmm
now a sense of overriding futility is a
vital part of the process
embrace it whatever you say doctor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i know just how you feel
man [ __ ] gotta be around here somewhere
unless they buried it under the sand
fool another brilliant lamar davis
production [ __ ] you hey excuse me homie
can you tell me where berto beach house
is
no homie i cannot man would you come on
[ __ ] actually yeah
it's that house right there with the
yellow stairs
yeah good looking at home appreciate it
man get your stupid ass on damn why
won't you ask him if he knows the
[ __ ] owner or better yet do some
skywriting that reads there's a couple
[ __ ] here about to boost some cars in
case somebody didn't realize see what
you don't realize that we ain't boosting
this [ __ ] is legit business legit oh
yeah i forgot huh 401ks tax returns and
all yeah right you don't want all pumped
up on doing this lick [ __ ] i'm getting
my money in the hood i'm straight fool
i'm cool you cool cool what slinging
dope and throwing up gang signs yeah
right whatever homie
yeah homie this is the spin knot right
here your boy simeon wasn't [ __ ]
man get your ass in me
bring your ass fool always trying to
boss somebody
come on
come on
[ __ ] come on
damn
this [ __ ] must got the baby dick
yeah and all this [ __ ] paid for with bad
credit
[Music]
come to daddy which one you want [ __ ]
[Music]
you always was old choosy [ __ ]
only child
oh you're balling hard with the drop top
huh i might just be whatever [ __ ] it
ain't gonna make you go no faster hit me
on the speakerphone i'm moving oh it's
like that [ __ ]
[Music]
hey remember we got to be careful with
these rides homie but simeon ain't about
to dock my play again homie man if you
need some bread i could hook you up with
jb's tow truck it ain't got glamour but
it's some money to be made so him and
tanya can smoke crack in peace homie i'm
good
if you want to get whips like this you
got to stay on your gridiron they can't
do some time over nickels and dimes i
stick to repos dog
[Applause]
right homie fine
let's show these movie people how we
roll
[Music]
oh we filming [ __ ] here huh
down this dirty [ __ ]
all right
remember this is your terry's car
hey i'll commit you from the shoulders
home
[Applause]
if you want to chunk them things
left here
yeah that's cool
[Applause]
well in that case we might as well enjoy
ourselves
[Applause]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you say
this meant to be your [ __ ]
whatever you say
we buzzing at you your depository
[ __ ] that's super bang
oh [ __ ]
what you gonna smoke the road for dawg
move over so the traffic can flow
through whatever [ __ ] i'll let
something flow through your ass dog
ain't too sure that joke works dog oh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] the one time be cool fool we got
the paperwork whatever you explain that
[ __ ] i see you at the dealership explain
that [ __ ] my ass
dog
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we got eyes on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]